okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p the
voicemail line very exciting is made
possible by our good friends over at
linguist which is a language learning
service that uses fine tuned repetition
powered by artificial intelligence to
make learning foreign language
vocabulary a breeze i've been using it
for weeks to improve my French and I've
been really impressed about how much
I've been able to accomplish with
linguist in a really short amount of
time try it free no credit card at Ling
viscom slash Pakman that's Ling vist
with a v.com slash Pakman okay
here's today's voice mail and I will set
it up for you when we take live calls it
is a persistent problem that even though
I always say don't be on voice on a
speakerphone even though the welcome
message when you call in on live calls
says turn speakerphone off and have your
question ready I would estimate that
roughly half of our callers are on
speakerphone and this really sort of
funny thing happens where I immediately
identify that they're on speakerphone
and I say are you on speakerphone
they almost invariably say no but
immediately we can hear them perfectly
because clearly they were on
speakerphone and they turned it off
anyway here's someone who called in I
guess trying to just spite me about
being on speakerphone David I'm on
speaker congratulations you got on
that's by the way one of the clearest
speaker phone calls we've ever received
I wouldn't even be worried about the
speakerphone stuff during live calls if
they sounded that that clear but they
don't and it's a problem please don't be
on speakerphone when you call into the
show life okay we have a great bonus
show for you today we are going to talk
about this very unusual story about a
teacher thinking it was a good idea to
do a mock slave auction in a fifth-grade
class I guess under the guise of
teaching the students about the history
of slavery in the United States
I remember in AP
knocks class in high school our teacher
mr. Baldwin had us do a fake stock
market where we would have some amount
of stock and a limited amount of time to
buy and sell it to sort of see how
negotiating and market dynamics worked
seems like an appropriate thing to do
with stocks in an economics class seems
maybe not like the best idea to do with
fake slaves in a 5th grade history class
we were also 16 to 18 years old when we
did this not ten or eleven so we will
talk about that on today's bonus show
number two there's a new app that will
help you find safe spaces if you want to
wear your mag at your Donald Trump read
make America great again hat without
being hassled so if you are triggered by
people who don't like the hats if you
need such a safe space there's an app
that will help you find those places and
lastly a Jaguar is not going to be
euthanized after a an attack that took
place at a zoo I believe this is the
right decision and I'll get into detail
about why on today's bonus show so to
get access to today's bonus show become
a member or a patron membership at WWN
pakman.com patreon at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and you'll get instant
access now I do want to sort of warn you
and we go back and forth pat about
whether we should tell people about this
or not ahead of time when there's a
guest host we have a guest host tomorrow
ok I'm gonna be on a plane to DC
tomorrow I have a bunch of meetings
there a bunch of very very exciting
things that are going to be taking place
there will be a guest host the Hess
guest host will be Ferren cousins our
primary two guest hosts over the last
year or so have been Ferren cousins from
Ring of Fire and Benjamin Dixon from the
Benjamin Dixon show whenever they are
here a bunch of people write to me and
they say awesome choice for a guest host
a bunch of people write to me and they
say absolutely terrible choice for a
guest host
I think what's clear Pat is that number
one no guest host will be liked by
everybody and number two a lot of people
don't even like me hosting the show it's
just like you know it's
my show so that's not going to change
and I think we just have to accept that
whether it's me or anyone else who's
hosting a lot of people aren't going to
like that person yeah well it is the
david pakman show and i feel like you
know not people can't do as good of a
job as you do hosting your own show no
one can ever be David Pakman like you
can and I understand that some people
say that we shouldn't have a show at all
when you're away and I don't see that
why why should we have no show as the
alternative to having a guest host if
you don't like the guest host just don't
watch but don't ruin it for everyone
else yeah well we used to do that we
used to not have a show when I would be
traveling or off on vacation and people
were furious saying David you really
just got to get a guest host in there
because we want to hear the news anyway
and it's a disruption and you have
enough staff that people can be rotating
through days off so that's what we did I
listened to people and now we have a
rotating cast of guest hosts and
invariably I get 150 emails no matter
who the guest host is telling me no show
is potentially better than the guest
host so anyway be nice to Ferren
tomorrow and I'll be back for the Friday
show